hi everyone my name is salt and we're
going to talk about performance Python
this is an iteration on a talk called
speed without drag it has turned into
speed with some drag and we'll see why
quick raise of hands who here when to PI
Gotham this year I got them no one
really Oh where's wally okay good that's
good because this is seventy percent of
this talk is a talk I gave my pike off
him so it's a good thing you you guys
didn't end cool but before that the one
thing I've learned from James Powell is
that you know you should talk about
yourself a lot so I'm going to tell you
who I am in first my name is all I'm
Spaniard in New York there's a joke
about sting there but the song
Englishman in New York I tried to crack
it in Germany I tried to crack it in
Spain it never works so I'm not going to
try cuz I keep making enemies anyway my
background is in EE electronics and then
also computer science because I did
electronics then I figure it out I
actually wanted to code so I went back
to school for a contact really smart I
work in that tech as the previous
speaker I work at thankful and we're
actually doing things in a similar way
they're doing it in fact which is
released introduction to data science
course in Python so check it out if
you're interested in that and before
that I used to work on at Tech
advertising facebook advertising because
we all know the world needs more of that
so I did that for a couple years and
that's where my where the data in my PI
data comes from
you can finally on that email you can
treat at me at that handle or if you
want to see the slides the ipython
notebook behind this that feels this
talk it's actually on PI data New York
City speed with some drag talk I did
lose the PSD I was using to to build
this little slide and between you know
giving you out of date ipython netbook
or not giving you that really beautiful
drawing of myself had I been born a
llama I chose to keep dilemma anyway so
by now you're probably are you're
probably wondering why are we hearing
why are we talking about about all this
and the origin for this talk it's
twofold I was talking about number
before and also I joined a company were
where I had a couple folks Ruby folks
and one JavaScript full moon JavaScript
guide it's always the JavaScript ones
that are like you know and you know they
say some things who here has ever heard
of that old saying oh you can't do that
with python python is just too slow who
here has reacted aggressively to today
all right so I'm gonna give you a couple
a couple you know arguments so you can
react aggressively next time some
smartest claims that now we're going to
talk about how to speed up numerical
Python when you don't actually want to
waste time but first I'm going to tell
you not to do it because you know i'm
i'm from from the north of Spain and we
have this habit of you know being
ambiguous so I'm going to tell you don't
do it there ain't no such thing as a
free lunch there ain't no such thing as
a free speed up and we'll see the thing
these libraries will help you but you
know it comes at a cost small but it
comes at a cost that's why we went from
without drag to some drag so think first
and then just don't do it don't try you
know you can think things through and
refactor your code and we'll see a
couple ways of doing that couple things
to like think before you go all the way
down to you know porting your code base
2 pi PI Jeff Bezos favorite throw money
at the problem by more machines cluster
eyes all the things and just don't don't
try to fix by thing just you know let
the CRO deal with it basically evaluate
the cost of opportunity cassettes I'm
saying you know it's not entirely free
so you probably want to figure out
whether or not it's things are worth it
or maybe you would rather be doing
something else and you know one another
job that doesn't really work is blame it
on resume and switch the Java not a good
one at pay data so on exhaustion C
Python i'm not doing i'm not using dis
libraries i'm talking about i urge you
to first look at your problem one of
them if you're if you do engineering
process as its suppose so you should be
profiling your coat and like
doing things so that you can so you so
that you actually know what the problem
is your ear code has there's a bunch of
stuff like IO waiting for a database
serialization many many problems your
code can have that this won't help you
with this libraries speeding speeding
numerical python won't help you if
you're just waiting for post words to to
come back to you so definitely look into
that there are like bloopers that you
can do while writing code such as
recompiling over and over again your reg
ex and sometimes you know your optimizer
your whatever won't catch that so we
write your code profile it make sure
that you know you are doing what you
should be doing and if you're discarding
any computation just don't do it if you
if your front ends gonna show an integer
there's no recent no good reason to be
using decimals in not decimals but you
know doubles in the back end sometimes
you use some randoms that you don't need
to use because you you would be ok with
pseudo random stuff many many many other
things this is not to talk for it but
there are many things that you should do
before you actually try you know doing
the use in the libraries we're going to
talk about I include a link there to
talk by Davis David shata on speeding up
programs really interesting completely
the opposite of this stock his stock
would basically be a speed with a lot of
drag but forgive really interesting talk
really good talk i recommend you i watch
it and then captured a little low
hanging fruit use multiprocessing
careful with the overhead and Amdahl's
law check many things like you know
proper use of data structures use the
language fully use pass the pen
comprehensions use generators for those
of you in New York don't use this code
but
this is not really what we came here to
talk about and what we're going to
discuss is what libraries and tools you
have to safely escape the safety of
Python which basically means that at the
end of the day what dis libraries will
help you do is step out of Python or
step out to a different PI thing that's
built in a different way so that your
code your algorithm is actually much
faster we've got many tools for that and
this is the D outline we have assassin c
pi things basically what i was talking
about about just not using any of the
rest then we have a cluster of libraries
that basically drop down to see fortran
c++ cuda even in order to escape that C
Python that might not be that fast then
we have parakeet in between the these
two groups parakeets started being like
numba and pison but turning to see I
guess openmp although I believe it's not
maintained anymore or its own hiatus
then we have number and pie stone which
basically not necessarily escape Python
as much as just use a different back-end
to translate it to machine code for
those of you familiar and they use llvm
and then we've got pie pie and numb pie
pie with it that's a complete different
compiler and jivin which is a python on
top of the JVM which is basically again
using a different back-end
we're going to go through some examples
really quickly without looking too much
into the performance stats and there's a
reason for that we're going to use this
example which is one of my former
favorite interview questions which is
given a list of coordinates for polygon
return its area the goal the goal of the
interview questions not to like you know
test your math but basically you're
googling scales and your coding skills
so we're going to try to speed this up
again we're not going to be looking too
much into the performance numbers
they're there to help us discern if
things are you know working or not but
in any case this is just one example
some libraries will do well some
libraries won't so basically grain of
salt don't don't read too much into the
numbers especially when you know there's
just one single piece of code a library
that's really good at doing GPU the
stuff probably won't work well and well
wear some others will excel so there's
that the solution in C Python well
before the solution we need to actually
generate dis polygons so what I wrote
was a really good-looking piece of code
here that returns a list of coordinates
for a polygon that's basically dad looks
like it's like some like a staircase
like a diagonal like that thing I joined
in the comment and you know this is
really this is beautiful code that works
I don't know how when when someone
writes code is ugly some people write a
talk and tell you not to use this code
I test it and you know put it in
production so that's what I do the code
is tested and it works and this is
actually the solution to it to the
actual problem this is the code we're
going to be speeding up or the D
algorithm rather it's basically the
summation of the 2 by 2 determinant some
of the ordered coordinates this is can
remember this is called a shoelace
formula it's a reduction of Gauss
theorem which in turns a simplification
of greens theorem and you know if you
want to look into it how about it but
it's it's it's pretty solid math anyway
we test that with a diagonal that's
200,000 blocks tall and we would take
one fourth of a second and then we're
going to start testing this new your
libraries syfy we all know side by side
pi is a community it's a stack it's an
ecosystem it is it is it used to be edit
it isn't it used to be to a library that
contains many helpful functions and then
the stack includes things like numpy
ipython and all these things were we're
by now used to we can't use syfy quote
unquote to solve this but we can use
numpy which is basically a part of of
sight pile as you know it's the DN
dimensional array library goes down to
see and Fortran really fast it needs no
introduction so when solving this with
numpy the only thing we need to do is
create an umpire ray out of that polygon
we generated and then we basically
rewrite the solution slice in the array
in a pretty normal fashion and just by
doing that we get a great speed up I
don't know what that is I think it's 70
X or something like that so pretty
brutal for pretty much no work
right next to it is numb exper which is
library partly written by my fellow
countryman friends desk I'll dead and
what num expert does is it basically
feeds your processor you're a raised in
a basically a piece of piecemeal fashion
so that all the caches are used fully
and that insole just that speeds things
up a lot and then there's a bunch of
stuff for for the vm l and the vector
math library in the kernel the math
kernal library for algebra well not
really algebra more complex math in
general if num exper supports what
you're doing you will see a performance
improvement over numpy in our case we
simply write the the calculation we're
doing and with that we get what 4x over
numpy so there's that Thea new this is
the library probably one of the most
mature libraries but one the one that
probably won't do us well here because
it's mostly aimed to do GPU processing
cuda and clusters and stuff like that it
kind of works as you can see here things
change a little bit more we're talking
about vectors and tensors but the
general look of the thing remains pretty
much the same and when when benchmarking
we get an improvement over C Python but
numpy and um expert still are still
faster depending on what you're doing
this will probably outpace them at some
point then we've got Python which is
basically a C++ transpiler Python will
Python will read your Python code in
translate
it into c++ and they do bunch of
optimization that's native to them SIMD
instructions pretty interesting library
not that well-known but definitely
interesting there's a talk by media many
from PI data so come Valley this year
that's interesting view if you're if
this packs your interest this is an
example of how it works you basically
annotate your code and then you run it
with with a third party that's how I was
saying was originally had originally an
LLB and back-end anyone here know what
llvm is okay um some hands llvm is it's
a big project but mostly it's an
optimizer in a in a back-end compiler
two different platforms what that means
is that if you know how to speak llvm
you can actually tell lvm to compile
things to machine code for many
platforms for free and it's really fast
it's something that was partly built at
Apple you might have heard of swift
swift is the new iOS programming
language is built on top of that there
are many things built on top of it to
really interesting really interesting
project anyway parakeets started with an
lvm back in that eventually got
deprecated in favor of C and OpenMP I
think Alex Rubenstein is here but I
think it's the development might have
stopped in any case what we do here is
and it's just in time thanks to ya what
we do here is decorate our code and just
we send it to parkade and park it
returns that machine code we were we
were talking about depending on the back
and you choose in
be faster or slower in our case you can
see how it's fairly fast the normal path
and implementation can be improved in
fact it kind of struggles with it but
the new pie's readily spit it out number
it's actually it's the library by
continuum analytics the sponsors and
it's basically this llvm stuff over a
subset of Python the subset that's
numeric because you know if you're
building strings over and over you
probably I mean you probably want to
speed that up but that's not numerical
python that llvm will help you speed up
what number does is exactly the same
that park it used to actually don't know
which which came first but in any case
it will read the abstract syntax tree of
your code it will translate it into this
llvm language which is where all the
work is in the library really and once
it's in that is llvm ir ir for
intermediate representation it just
sends it to llvm gets the machine code
back and runs it your scooter support
and there's some stuff cool stuff for
static compilation because initially
this is jaded and there's a pro version
with multi-core and GPU and that kind of
stuff if you're not bored by now by me
there's to talk about numba on PI data
last year if you're interested and the
way this looks is exactly the same you
decorate your one of your methods that
includes just that subset of Python that
support it and then you run it and in
doing that you get you get a speed up
for free in our in this case for this
particular problem it doesn't excel one
would i would expect number to do as
well or close to parakeet in this case
number struggles with with a certain
thing with the erase which I
I already figured out but I lifted there
for a reason to drive appointed we will
talk later we can skip this number can
vectorize your methods if you're into
that it's really helpful if if you use
numpy and you tend to vectorize things
that is really helpful pie pie pie pie
is a just-in-time compiler of Python
that's completely separated from C
Python this is this is already just
we're not trying to realize circumvent C
Python anymore but we're just using
another implementation of Python it's
really fast it's pretty much sure lots
of support really worth looking into
give never used it in fact I think it's
the fastest thing here other than para
que dinuba probably here we drop down to
the shell we're not running tests in our
ipython notebook anymore who are using
the shoelace that be why that's included
in in here which is exactly the same
code same terrible beautiful-looking
code and when we run it we get that
reading if we run it in Python we get
that rating so you can see how pipe is
much much faster much much faster using
the exact same code that's the vanilla
sea python solution there's a numpy pie
port it's a fork numpy as I said
basically drops out to sea and Fortran
so you can't really do that in pie pie
so they have to like figure out some
things and like change some things the
the fork you know it's getting a lot of
attention in a lot of work but it's not
really good yet but it does work meaning
if you have Co dad has an empire you can
probably run it in pipe I've if you go
with something else that being said for
at least for this example it's this the
cpat the vanilla python is faster than
no pie that's just the code for doing
that jonathan is again
not the normal Python not C Python which
is what we tend to use right it's again
a different implementation of Python in
this case we're executing Python on top
of the JVM the java virtual machine
which can be fast or slow in our in this
particular case i think it doesn't do to
it does better than Python but not
better than pi PI so you know it's some
somewhere in between it's not a I'm
tempted to say it's not as mature as pie
pie but I might be wrong but you know as
you can see it's already faster than
somewhat bastard and the Python didn't
see Python if you don't take into
account jbm startup time this is a
comparison between these ones that we
tested outside of the ipython notebook
pi pi is the leading one then numpy and
magnum PI pi and pi sting is a new
just-in-time compiler that greater van
rossum is working on which is basically
all it's basically the same thing that
numbers doing only you know they got
more lofty goals and they're trying to
put the entirety of python on top of
llvm and then they're trying to do other
stuff too especially when it comes to
optimization in garbage collection and
some other stuff a huge huge project
really new doesn't even working you know
sex yet there are many parts missing
last time I checked they had just
implemented exceptions so definitely not
production ready but you know it's that
it's word where the future is kind of
headed in this regard and you'll see a
trend here with two three basic
directions once dropping down to see
while not leaving C Python the llvm
direction and then the screw this i'm
going to build my own interpreter my own
front of my own back in my own optimized
I own everything and when L else fails
again you can actually do the work Red
Sea and appended to to see python that
link there is a it hub repo by a
gentleman Sam called Sammy Villar that
basically implemented in in hardcore see
using SIMD and all that stuff the same
polygon area problem the problem with
this is that it does look like this and
you have to actually write it so in any
case the last that my parting thought on
this is the qualification some debt that
this has and this is why they talk
changed from without drag to with sound
drag the moment you start using
something like this you are introducing
debt debt into your system to some to
some degree and this is going to be a
seemingly obvious reminder not to trust
your bread in this room we probably have
two different types of brain once the
scientists brain which is like I just
want to speed up my code I'll do
whatever i'll i'll include a binary
there whatever needs to be done i'll do
it i don't care and then we've got the
other brain that's the engineering brain
it's cool which tells you well it's
basically tells you hey this is really
cool we need to do this we're going to
use the new new bat and probably by
throwing in there too because this is
going to be awesome i'm telling you do
not do that there are threats to that
there's a third brain that you need to
listen to which is the software
management brain whatever you want to
call it the it's probably the brain that
vs suit to work and you know it's pretty
stock up but it might have a point which
is if you if you start using Thea new on
your on your production environment and
you know you basically do it a little
bit you by
make it work next summer come May when
when the new interns come you know you
were doing what I call your Jenga coding
the interns are going to crash into your
Jenga coding you know it's not going to
be fun so think about that because you
know one of the things I tend to say at
work is think of the interns ain't
nobody going to think of the interns so
do think about the interns out on this
because this is something they will
probably not enjoy nurse debt which is
that basically you know when you leave
some someone else will have to pick up
your really interesting Python
implementation and then there's another
thing that it's not as obvious which is
the product development risk depending
on where when your project goes
depending on where you're going with
your code a solution that once seemed
like it was perfect it was you know
you're dropping I don't know pi PI and
everything just works come next month
when the product guy asks you for a
dashboard on this and this and that and
you have to do another group buying
whatever your code won't work anymore
and you will spend two months trying to
make pi PI work or I'm not trying to
target pipe I'm just saying you know
things that come for free sometimes when
you just drop one of these libraries in
your code base might not work as well
when when the next features is asked of
you so you have to take that into
account too and to recap it's not free
no free lunches no free speedups think
first and try to avoid this again don't
don't listen to your engineering brain
that tells you hate is going to be
awesome we're going to be using llvm
everywhere use the best tool for the job
try to figure out which which of the
libraries will help you to most with
while doing the the smallest you know
work
while using the second best tool for any
job which is Python that's really corny
and again don't trust your scientist or
engineer brain trust the brain into suit
thank you now if we have time for
questions yep not only sports 5 19.6 yep
hey exactly yeah jython par kid I think
hasn't gotten a single coming since
March this year and that's why I'm
saying you know don't trust your
engineer brain that just wants to go at
it trust the one with the suit that
tells you hey this library is not
maintained or hey if we use numpy pie we
won't be able to use these things that
they haven't implemented yet and that
kind of thing because it's really easy
to get really excited about getting it
done or doing cool engineering things
and six months later you're going to be
hating yourself the interim might hate
yours you too and the boss might hate
you too so
no thank you